على بعد سبعه كيلومترات من خط الجبهه على
مشارف الدومباس اجتماع لوحده الدبابات
الاوكرانيه الجو بارد وتساقط الثلج يضمن
للجنود عدم وجود طائرات بدون طيار روسيه
تكشف مواقعهم وتستهدفهم تختبئ الدبابات
بين الاشجار في هذه الغابه الصغيره تشكل
خطا دفاعيا ثانيا جاهزا للقتال لكن
الياتهم محدوده القدرات
في الماضي كانت هذه الدبابه جيده جدا
وكانت تقانيتها سريه للغايه
لكنها الان قديمه ويصعب القتال فيها
انظروا انها قديمه عجوز مثلي
يضيق داخلها بالطاقم المكون من ثلاثه جنود
يقول قائدهم ان معنويات الجنود عاليه
لكنهم ينتظرون بفارغ الصبر رؤيه دبابات
الالمانيه التي وعدت بها اوكرانيا
القضيه الرئيسيه هي تلك الدبابات الغربيه
اذا حصلنا على جميع الدبابات التي طلبها
القائد العام فيمكننا تغيير كثافه وشكل
قتالنا بالكامل وبعد ذلك يمكننا طردهم من
بلدنا نحن حقا بحاجه الى تلك الدبابات في
ظل الخوف من هجوم الروسي في اي وقت يجب
عليه عمل كل ما بامكانه لجعل هذه الدبابات
القديمه جاهزه للقتال حان وقت اختبار
دبابه 64
شغل المحرك
[موسيقى]
الان كل شيء على ما يرى تعود لمكانها بين
الاشجار في وضعيه قتاليه في هذه الوحده
ثلاث دبابات قديمه وعرضه للاعطال
الميكانيكيه فهذه الدبابه التي عادت من
الجبهه قبل ايام كانت قد دمرت خمسه دبابات
روسيه منذ بدايه الحرب
هذه دبابه للجيش الاوكراني من طراز تي 64
سوفيتيه الصنع يقضي الجنود 70% من وقتهم
في اصلاحها وثلاثين في المئه في ساحه
المعركه
حان الوقت لاخذ قسط من الراحه يتعين على
طواقم الدبابات الاخرى التي تقاتل في
الحقول حفره خنادقهم بجانب الياته طاقم
الدبابه هذه محظوظ يمكنه الاستراحه في
منزل في قريه مجاوره المكان ضيق فسبعه
جنود ينامون في هذه الغرفه ووسائل الراحه
محدوده هذه هي الظروف التي نعيشها انها
تجعلنا اكثر غضبا من عدونا النصر ثم النصر
هذا ما اقوله دائما لافراد طاقه يجب ان
يؤمنوا بذلك
فهم على استعداد دائم للرحيل
املوا ان نتمكن من اجبار الروس على الخروج
بحلول نهايه الربيع
بعون الله وشركائنا سنطردهم من بلادنا ثم
نعيش بسلام ونعود الى عائلاتنا
كتبوا على الجدار اسلام اوكرينه تحيا
اوكرانيا ولم يروا عائلاتهم منذ اشهر رسوم
اطفالهم تذكرهم قبل الذهاب الى الجبهه
ان هناك من ينتظر عودتهم